on the roof of this maximum security
prison wing inmates in cuenca ecuador
call out for help
inside they say it's too dangerous
some were evacuated but most were
trapped by prison riots
we've been waiting here for more than 20
hours i've been standing here listening
to the inmates cry out for help
more than 800 officers responded but
they struggled to stop the violence the
interior minister says tougher laws are
needed
prisons unfortunately have become a
permanent threat it's been like this for
some time but today we want to and we
will take necessary action
drug wars in ecuador have led to a surge
in gangs fighting over the lucrative
drug trade the competition often extends
into prisons more than 300 inmates were
killed last year
we need help there are people who are
being killed it's wrong
the country's 65 prisons have a capacity
for 30 thousand people but some
government officials are concerned
overcrowding could further magnify the
tension
and violence
katya lopez of the young al jazeera